why is Putin not yet using low-yield
nukes to just clear the field and take
the land uh because he hasn't been in a
desperate enough situation thus far once
you do that you know it's it's
it is an escalation there is a risk that
you know uh potentially you know we'll
I'll give you an example once this
happens and he gets away with it I think
he would get away with it the US is not
going to respond with the nuclear attack
on Russia if they do a nuclear
detonation in Ukraine that would be
insane for President Biden to do he
would not do that so if they do that and
he gets away with it now what's going to
happen to nuclear non-proliferation
because we've told all our NATO members
and Japan and so many countries we will
protect you with our nuclear umbrella
and it's not believable it's never been
credible and this will prove that it's
not credible that we will not use
nuclear weapons most likely even to
defend our allies in Ukraine you know
thus far is not a NATO member not an
ally we have to defend